so it's been a good while since your
last animated feature so why the return
now was it an itch to get back to the
format or was it the scoob script in
particular it was definitely not an itch
to get back to the format it's so hard
it's like so much harder than I ever
thought it was gonna be but the scoop
the legs like being a part of this whole
franchise the big deal and you know as
someone I didn't have a child when I did
the first animated movie and it you know
you do really consider them more than
ever when you got a kid so this was like
oh I would outplay whoever you want me
to play in this is there anything about
the epic experience that did make you
think wow like that is especially
challenging when voicing a character and
I don't know if I can do that again it
can be really really just drawn out and
and you know boring at times I guess
because you you've got this great
charismatic director and both
experiences I've had like really great
directors who can play every character
for me but you know not being in a dark
room for hours and saying these lines
over and over again and losing yourself
if not knowing exactly how it's even
coming across because you can't hear
after a while how it sounds you have to
express yourself through just your voice
and I'm so used to being able to use my
mannerisms in my face and you know it's
my physicality and you don't have that
here it's just it's definitely a
different type of acting is there
anything about the voice acting process
that has changed drastically between
then and now that you had on Scoob that
you didn't before yes I I did a play
where I had to really work on my
projection really like you know it gave
me such good experience like talking in
a way that feels natural but loud and
that really helps it really really helps
Express you know certain things and we
took
into nations and stuff so yeah okay so I
have a throwback question for you now
because I just got into an argument
about this with someone it's a Mean
Girls question and it do you think that
Karen ever actually wrote anything in
the burn book
cuz I'm of the mind that she didn't know
no she did she totally didn't she was a
part of it but she didn't
it's just nothing to say about anything
anybody that's just nothing mean to say
about anybody she's just associated with
people who are very insecure and you
know I don't think if she was just
without the plastics I don't think she
would I don't I don't think she would be
a insecure
I mean her nail stuck but like that's
all she can say about herself I'm pretty
sure that's the right answer now I just
won this argument thanks to you yeah in
honor of Shaggy and Scooby I do want to
know what is the most outrageous or
ridiculous meal that you make for
yourself there was this like weird
recipe book and I have no as if you
don't know where it came from but it was
a snack that used to make that I've been
creeping lately and it's rice krispies
with a little bit of melted butter and
and shredded cheddar cheese on top
toasted that sounds just amazing and if
I take everybody's advice with what to
eat in this junket I'm gonna have sugar
overload oh really
oh no there's no sugar in this one
that's the thing that's just basically
sneeze and I'm sorry I forgot flat you
you you have to have butter I was like
I'm missing its butter and rice krispies
and flour and you put it in and you can
achieve it on top and toast it sorry
this is not they're not talking like
rice krispie treats here no this is like
this is savory this is like cholesterol
okay so now I've got the balance between
sweet and cholesterol I'm fine right I
mean if you want to go sweet oh I can't
even durian the other thank you so much
for your time today and big congrats on
the movie thank you home so bad it's
finally coming out thank you so much